morning spoilers ahead Dr Fate lectured
Black Adam on Earth so why did a
surprise guest come to chit chat and
who's the real hero in this movie
if you saw the 2019 film Shazam then you
may recall the scene in which Billy
Batson is first transported to the rock
of Eternity to meet the wizard Shazam my
name is
wait for real as Billy tries to make
sense of what's going on Shazam explains
that he is the last of the Council of
wizards and he is looking for someone
pure of her to pass his powers onto in
order to protect Humanity from the seven
deadly sins the reason he has to be so
picky is because the last time the power
was passed to someone it didn't go so
well we learn a bit more about that in
this film because Black Adam or teth
Adam as he's originally called is the
reason Shazam has to be careful about
who gets the powers but still with the
stamina of Shu the speed of Horus the
strength of almond the wisdom of zahuti
the powers of arten and the courage of
Mahan Adam used his incredible powers to
seek revenge on the ruler of Khan dark
instead of being the hero the seven
Wizards intended a story of Black Adam
is about the character gradually getting
to a place mentally where he can embody
some of the attributes the Wizards were
looking for however since he was not the
one they initially chose to wield the
power he will never become a traditional
hero
five thousand years after teth Adam
brought down uncut a woman named Adriana
Thomas releases him from his prison by
speaking the words engraved on the seal
trapping him in some kind of limbo State
the second he shows up Adam goes on a
lightning spitting Rampage as he kills
the soldiers coming at him with guns and
tanks and all sorts of useless weapons
since the Legends say that Seth Adam
will return When kondak needs him most
everyone naturally assumes that this
super strong guy who looks like the
statue they built thousands of years ago
is there to rescue them from intergang
Unfortunately they couldn't be more
wrong the only reason Adam has killed
those men is because they were in his
way and they were attacking him he has
no intention of saving anyone this
doesn't fit with all the Legends they've
heard and there's a good reason for that
this isn't the teth Adam the Wizards
initially chose to have their powers
they selected the boy harut who was the
son of the man currently carrying the
name teth Adam her route gave his powers
to his father to protect him but was
assassinated shortly after therefore on
the Man flying around modern day Khan
duck is a broken father who's lost the
only thing he ever loved and who sees
his own existence as a curse
the Justice Society of America is called
in to take Adam into custody because he
poses a threat to the safety of the
United States and every other country in
the world if he were to suddenly decide
he'd like to rule the world black Adam's
rage and thirst for vengeance release
her seven deadly sins upon the world
resulting in sets of the seven Wizards
getting obliterated and entire
civilizations being wiped out despite
being the good guys the Justice Society
has inherited Amanda Waller's
sanctimonious attitude when it comes to
what Heroes can and cannot do aside from
continuously lecturing Adam on proper
heroic etiquette they also just assume
that the people of Khan dock are also
going to step aside for the Justice
Society why because they're the ones
with the superpowers therefore they know
best you think yourself a hero but you
would let these criminals Go free Heroes
don't kill people however this is a
country that has been invaded and
occupied for years and the ones that the
Justice Society come to help only after
the JSA can learn to work work with Adam
and the citizens of Khan dock are they
able to get any work done we can see
that's at the end when instead of
charging in and destroying things Atom
Smasher and Cyclone use their powers to
work in tandem with the people
when Black Adam opens we're given a very
detailed breakdown of everything that
went down in Khan dark in the year 2600
BC thanks to a voiceover from the
character Amman Tomas he tells us about
how a magical element called the
eternium can be found in Khan dark and
that an ancient ruler had a slave's dig
for the element in order to forge the
crown of sabark so he could wield
ultimate power however Black Adam took
the crown and destroyed his Empire in
this prologue we see her root with an
old man but once we get the full story
we realize that the old man was actually
the boy's father and he looks remarkably
like a Black Adam while it's not
confusing at first this actually
demonstrates just how much of Khan dogs
pass and resources have been co-opted by
outside forces over the centuries when
the Justice Society explains they've had
access to ancient texts that say Black
Adam was a destroyer instead of a hero
iman's mother Adriana doesn't believe
them it is very likely that people have
been coming to Khan dark and stealing
from it so much that even its own
history is incomplete therefore when we
see him on story what we're seeing is
his interpretation of events not the
events as they actually unfolded this
stands as yet another reason why Khan
dark needs a protect her to keep the
history intact I kneel before no one
when the truth comes out that Black Adam
isn't the hero of Legend he agrees to go
the JSA to be locked up forever he
doesn't want these Powers anymore since
he never felt worthy of them to begin
with he makes the JSA promise that after
he says Shazam and transforms back to
his original form they will never allow
him to speak the word again he is tired
of carrying this burden and welcomes the
idea of being free of it even if that
means being locked up they take him to
an underwater task force x prison run by
Amanda Waller she of course is a
director of Argus an agency that engages
in numerous clandestine missions across
the globe to make sure superhumans do
not threaten the security of the United
States task 4 sex is the division of
Argus where imprisoned villains in the
DC Universe are used to carry out many
of those missions in exchange for time
off for their sentences you might
remember them better as a Suicide Squad
we consider that term degrading the
official term is task force x when the
members of the JSA arrive they're
greeted by Amelia harcourts fans of the
HBO series Peacemaker will likely
remember her as an NSA agent working for
Waller in that series and in the film
The Suicide Squad she points out that
the gods were meant to be Humanity's
Heroes but Humanity seems to be the one
always burying them all of this suggests
that task force x is powerful enough to
control Adam funny for you are often the
only choice in killing people coincides
Dr Fate is a man with a thousand storm
clouds swirling over his head at all
times as a sentient alien helmet of
Naboo he wears reveals every possible
version of the future he knows that the
future is Unwritten but due to
circumstances out of his control he
can't always predict which series of
events will unfold his job is to step in
and make sure that the decisions made by
the JSA result in the best possible
outcome throughout much of the film he
is dreading the completion of the
mission because he knows the version of
events where they saved the day requires
his friend Hawkman to die nothing but
Hardy when zabark arises from the
underworld to conquer Earth fate knows
the happy ending is approaching but he's
not about to let Hawkman go he steps in
and sacrifices himself while doing so he
uses his power to be in two places at
once to free Adam because he knows Adam
is the only one powerful enough to
defeat sabark he tells Adam that he
should accept his abilities because fate
doesn't make mistakes and at that moment
Dr Fate has literally chosen Adam to
save you Humanity whether he wants it or
not fate sacrifice also allows Hawkman
to hold the helmet in order to multiply
himself and distract sabark turning the
tide of the battle
despite as many faults the antagonists
of the film isn't actually Black Adam
it's a man named Ishmael at first he
appears to be working with Adriana to
help free Khan dark but he's actually
looking for the crown of sabark no one
really knows why he wants it so they
check the engraving within it only to
find that it reads that life is the only
road to death which seems obvious what
they don't know is that the power from
the crown comes from the underworld
which serves as a dark reflection of our
world this means the inscription is
really telling them that death is the
only road to life Ishmael wants a crown
because he is the descendant of King
uncut and only his bloodline can wear
the crown and use its power when Ishmael
gets the crown he is killed and sent to
the underworld where six demons grants
him the evil version of black Adam's
Power and he rises from that realm to
command an undead Army to conquer the
world Black Adam is the only one who can
stop him after briefly visiting the
afterlife where his son tells him it
isn't his time yet Adam returns to Khan
dark and battles the bark while he
handles that ordinary citizens fight his
skeleton army finally Adam rips the bark
in half destroying the crown and subox
power at least freeing Khan dark for now
that is we'll take care of the breath
as the dust begins to settle and
everyone realizes the battle has been
won the question posed to Adam is
whether or not he is willing to be Khan
dog's hero he destroys the throne meant
for their savior because it feels wrong
even after 5 000 years of imprisonment
Adam knows that Khan dark doesn't need a
ruler it needs people who are willing to
work together to return to its former
glory condark already has Heroes he says
having met people like Adriana and her
son Amman who believes in Khan dark and
want to see it Thrive again their hearts
and intentions are pure unlike his own
this goes back to the start of the film
when her root stresses a need for
everyone to stand up and fight their
enslavers when everyone else is too
scared Adriana and Amana this
generation's version of heroot within to
gangan and sabar killed they can
organize the citizens to work together
while that's going on condog still needs
to protect her someone who can stand in
the way when an invading force shows up
looking to occupy them again thus is a
role Adam is more comfortable with
because he still isn't one for rescuing
people he will not save conduct but he
will punish and Destroy anyone who
thinks they can invade it this is a sign
that he is moving away from being a
total anti-hero and compromising a
little bear
Adam is released from his prison and
enter the world already flush with
super-powered beings capable of
incredible Feats by the end of the film
Adam has been reborn his suit is more
vibrant he's been encouraged by the
spirit of his son to do more and he even
changes his name to Black Adam thus he
is more reminiscent of the character we
know from the comics a character capable
of doing good but with dubious morals
and the potential to go from good to
evil depending on the situation this is
perhaps why Amanda Waller isn't very
happy about Sin that remaining in her
underwater prison
once the end credit sequence comes to a
close we Fade up to see a drone
descending from the sky before Black
Adam a hologram of Amanda Waller
projects from the device and she as
usual doesn't look very happy she tells
him that since he won't be staying in a
prison he is required to remain in Khan
dark if he steps Beyond its borders
she'll make sure it's the last thing he
ever does since he isn't fond of serving
a Master Adam tells her no one on earth
can stop him she threatens a call in a
favor with beings from other planets he
tells her to send them all the Hologram
ends and we see Superman emerge from the
Shadows he tells Adam that it's been a
while since anyone has frightened the
people of Earth quite as much as he has
suggesting that black Adam's presence is
akin to the arrival of Superman himself
although he says he just wants to talk
black Adam's penchant for foregoing
discussion and favor of violence pretty
much guarantees a conversation will not
go well perhaps that means a sequel
could feature a fight between Black Adam
and Superman hopefully a potential Black
Adam 2 can also explain why Superman
would do favor for someone like Waller
given her Shady tactics perhaps she
didn't send him and he really did just
come to talk
[Music]